so you've got a chart that kind of leads
into this um it's the financial
conditions remain uncomfortably loose
which is very different story than what
i think we're hearing in the uh kind of
public narrative right everyone's
talking about quantitative tightening
they've uh started to conduct that
they're raising interest rates there's
been tough talks since like november of
last year uh by the federal reserve but
this chart's telling a little bit of a
different story so explain kind of what
this is uh what this is showing us and
like why why is the data showing us
something different than maybe the
public narrative yeah no 100 man so this
this is a really important chart and i
want everyone to sort of take some time
to kind of understand this the red line
just shows the goldman sachs financial
conditions index uh basically how to
interpret the chart is when it's low
that means combination conditions are
loose they're you know very
accommodative and when the index is high
as a high value the means capacitance is
very tight we've seen a decent
tightening off the lows in the red line
but if you look at it on a historical
basis i mean we're basically about as
loose as we were
at the peak of the dot-com bubble in
terms of you know so if you think about
this in terms of the fed's inflation
fighting uh directive they haven't
really done anything to get growth to
slow down enough to cause inflation to
slow down which tells you that hey as an
investor here we might have you know
seen some pretty significant declines
off the highs and you know crypto
bitcoin etc uh but they could get a lot
worse if the fed is going to be
successful in achieving its inflation
objective
so when you start to think about this
there's
this whole idea of quantitative
tightening and really over the last 13
15 years whatever you want to kind of
count
there's been a very loose monetary
policy they at one point did try to
conduct quantitative tightening it
didn't go so hot they basically waved
the white flag very quickly they went
back to loose monetary policy explain to
people in you know kind of one or two
sentences like when you think of
quantitative tightening what should they
be paying attention to or like what are
the important things to watch as they
start to conduct this
oh well i mean number one i mean what's
the level of volatility both implied and
realized in financial markets because
what happens when the fed does it starts
to shrink its balance sheet we all
understand that qe is positive for
markets but the reason is positive for
markets is mostly due to a substitution
effect we're taking
safe securities out of the marketplace
and leaving investors uh you know
whether they be
asset managers you know retail investors
ultimately through mutual funds etcetera
with a bunch of cash that's burning a
hole in their pocket that needs to go to
work if they're trying to generate a
legitimate return you know a real return
and so the content of tightening
effectively works in reverse the fed is
now creating a hole on the on the on the
sort of the risk-free end of that
spectrum and now a lot of the money has
to rush it from the uh the further out
on the wrist curve to capitalize the u.s
government and it's just you know
creating this sort of vacuum the sucking
effect on that the further outs on the
risk curve so um you know when you said
quantitative tightening they tried it
and then they waved the white flag
you're absolutely right and the scary
part about this particular time around
is that not only are they going to do
quantitative tightening into a global
growth slow down a u.s growth slowdown
but more importantly they're going to
try to get to a double from the previous
pace of quantitative tightening we've
never seen this before we've never seen
the fed hiking interest rates 50 bips at
a time doing 50 to 100 billion dollars
of quantitative tightening at a time as
they will be in a few months and so i
think it's a real so it's a science
experiment to say the least
when you think of that
if they've never done this before at the
speed severity you know kind of
simultaneous actions the whole thing
should we throw out all historical
analysis uh because this is a new
environment and something that we
haven't seen before or do you think
history can still serve as a great guide
uh as we evaluate what could happen in
the future
you know 100 you don't want to throw out
historical analysis and analogs but what
you do want to understand is that
everything financial markets operate
from a rate of change perspective and
particularly rate of change relative to
expectations and so you know when you
look at the world through that sort of
you know frac that that that very
quantitative lens rate of change what's
happening at the margin what's changing
at the margins you then can bring in the
historical analogs that help you uh
identify hey you know the fed might be
shrinking its balance sheet with bigger
numbers now but on a relative basis to
what the balance sheet was this is you
know what's called a one sigma move uh
lower or two sigma move lower so you can
normalize things and help you create
more scientific and more thoughtful
analogs using historical data and the
reality is when you're talking about the
kind of gross slowdown that our models
are projecting at the same time you have
a quantitative tightening episode you're
talking about anything on the order of
20 to 30 percent analyze declines in s p
40 to 50 percent annualized declines in
high beta stocks and 60 i utilize
declines in something like bitcoin um
this is a really negative a macro
environment from a flows perspective um
so all bets are off if you think about
uh you know trying to buy the dip here
at which a lot of investors have done